a California Republican congressional
candidate recently learned what it's
like to have powerful tech companies
dictate what can and cannot be said
Elizabeth Penn created this campaign ad
in Cambodia under Pol Pot's Khmer Rouge
being young and single often meant a
gruesome life and likely death
they approached my father
and in order to save his life he said he
was about to be married
they asked him to whom he pointed to the
prettiest girl that he saw having never
spoken to her before 41 years later
there's still the happiest couple I know
great things can come from great
adversity Facebook blocked that ad on
the grounds that it contained quote
shocking disrespectful or sensational
content they have since relented in the
face of public backlash Elizabeth Hang
joins us now Elizabeth at one level this
is extraordinarily stupid because this
is actually your family's story and
Facebook is telling you that you telling
your family's story is some kind of hate
crime in their wacky world yeah
definitely so I found it incredibly
frustrating when I got into the race to
run for Congress a big part of my
message is that great things can come
from great adversity my parents survived
the Khmer Rouge in Cambodia and genocide
came to the United States as refugees
and for some reason these [ __ ] in it
like that message and revoked my ability
to promote this ad on their platform now
the Khmer Rouge in there mercifully
brief time in Cambodia managed to kill
well over a million people I mean they
were butchers Pol Pot and his allies
were butchers on a an incredible scale
do you think it's just that some twit at
Facebook who's got no memory of anything
before 2012 thinks that somehow your ad
was promoting genocide are they really
that stupid
now you know and we just constantly see
how this is an attack off from liberal
tech companies that continue to go after
conservative voices this that what I
showed or just glimpses of genocide my
family lived through it for a tech
company to be able
to say what history lives on I find
highly problematic well that's an
absolutely critical point because the
point you're making there is it's not
just that Facebook dominates our present
and our future but they're basically
unilaterally deciding for themselves
what part of the past were allowed to
know about so for example what happened
in Cambodia some social justice pajama
boy at Facebook decides that that simply
can be erased and two and a half billion
Facebook users aren't entitled to see it
yeah and the fact that it took I try to
go through the normal protocols when it
was first revoked and when I had to no
avail I took this publicly it took five
days and a whole national movement in
order for them to say I apologize for
the confusion
had I been I say a liberal in Los
Angeles I don't think that this would
have taken five days and a national
movement because my bigger concern is
what if this happened five days before
an election no you're absolutely you're
absolutely right in your and people who
aren't in a position to go public have a
much more difficult time Elizabeth
thanks for that thanks for your
inspiring story and your family story
and good luck in your election